[موسيقى]
مساء الخير حلقه جديده في مسلسل حلقات
افكار الاستاذ والدكتور جوده عبد الخالق
وموضوع النهارده يعني مثير للفضول على
الاقل من جانبي والحقيقه من جانب عدد كبير
جدا من الناس وافضل ان اطرحه في شكل سؤ
سؤال مساء الخير معالي الدكتور مساء
الجمال والحريه ربنا يخليك معالي الدكتور
عندي سؤال اتمنى ان اجد له اجابه مختصره
لماذا وكيف يتم التعامل مع القمح كسلاح
للضغط على الدول من جانب دول اخرى طبعا
ليه الاول المفروض ان القمح ا في ما يكفي
في العالم كله من الانتاج القمح يعني انا
يعني عندي ارقام كتيره لكن افضل حضرتك
تقول يعني ونحن نتابع ما هو حاال
سواء بالقريب منا
جدا في غزه او في اوكرانيا او في
السودان حديث عن
حرب يعني بالمعنى العادي جدا الاله
العسكريه هي اللي بتوظف فيها اسلحه وزخائر
وصواريخ وكل الكلام ده دي الحرب العسكريه
ولكن هناك ما يسمى الحرب الاقتصاديه
ايكونوميك
ورفير ده موضوع قام بذاته وله اساسياته
و التاريخ البشري حافل
بامثله لما يسمى الحرب الاقتصاديه الاساس
في الحرب الاقتصاديه هو استغلال مجتمع
حاجه مجتمع اخر لشيء ما سواء القمح في
حالتنا او لشيء اخر محتاج لتمويل سبيل
فيحجب عنه التمويل كما حدث مع روسيا على
سبيل مسال فلما في هذه الحاله يعتبر القمح
احد ادوات الحرب الا اقتصاديه التي تسها
تمارسها الدول
متنفذه وفي الصداره هنا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في مواجهه الدول
الاخرى لاسباب متعدده يعني قد تكون هناك
وبالتالي لان القمح متصل بوجود الانسان
يعني بمعنى ان يكون او لا يكون وليس كيف
يكون من لا يكن سيموت طبعا
وبالتالي هذه الخاصيه التي يتمتع بها
القمح دي ممكن تستغنى عن اشياء كثير لكن
الغذاء يعتبر ضروره الضروريات ف ده اللي
بيؤه القمح على سبيل المثال يكون احد ا
ادوات الحرب الاقتصاديه انجاز التعبير
عاوز استاذن حضرتك الاول علشان تكون
الصوره واضحه لمن يتابعنا قبل مسال عن
حضرتك ازاي وليه ا امثله على استخدام
الامح القمح كسلاح ا هل في امثله واضحه
كيف استخدمت الولايات المتحده او غيرها في
في امثله واضحه ربما اهم مثال بالنسبه لنا
ومنطقتنا من العالم هو ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اوقفت مراكب القمح
المتحركه منها الى مصر الكلام ده كان في
منتصف الستينات من القرن الماض 63 63 او
65 خلينا نقول
منتصف القرن الماضي وطبعا عنما نعود
بالذاكره الى الستينات
تجد مصر ممثله في زعامتها بقياده عبد
الناصر ذ الحين
كانت تقف موقف يختلف عن الرؤى
الامريكيه بالنسبه لترتيب الاوضاع في
المنطقه الولايات المتحده كانت تسعى في
ذلك الحين الى تكوين
حلف يقال انه مناوئ للشيوعيه اسمه حلف
بغداد اه طبعا ومصر كانت تعارض ومصر كانت
دوله متنفذه في في الاقليم وبالفعل لم
تتمكن الولايات المتحده ا من تنفيذ مخططها
بانشاء حلف بغداد ظل حبرا على ورق انما ا
في في هذا الاطار الولايات المتحده توسلت
بوسائل كثيره جدا منها موضوع موضوع وقف
شحنه القمر شحنات القامه التي كان متعاقد
عليها وتم تسويه تمن هذه المساله تتعلق ده
عمل من اعمال القرصنه انجاز التعبير
بتتكلم على شحنات تنفيذ لعقود قائمه ايام
الرئيس جونسون على ما اذكر ايام الرئيس
جونسون في هناك وايام الرئيس عبد الناصر
هنا الامثله كثيره مثلا اللي هو دلاله
القمح انه في سياق اجتماعي واقتصادي معين
هو اهم اهم سلع غذائيه بالنسبه للانسان
كويس ولكن في سياقات اخرى بيطلع س انيه
وليس القام لو خدنا دول شرق اسيا على سبيل
المثال وجنوب اسيا الارز او السلع ولذلك
بقول انه الرز هناك القمح هنا القصه واحده
الجوهر واحد بيتم استخدام الارز كسلاح في
دول شرق اسيا اه طبعا ولهذا السبب حدما
تقرا تاريخ بلد زي اليابان تج اليابان
فرضت على نفسها عزله دوليه
لا تتعامل مع الخارج
اساسا مش بقول بتاتا لما اساسا لانه
تصورهم انه نحن مجموعه جزر ويمكن لاي واحد
بقوه بحريه متواضعه فرض الحصار علينا فاما
ان نموت جوعا او نستسلم فاذا اردنا ان
نحتفظ بقدر من الاراده الوطنيه لنفعل ما
نحب ونريد يبقى لابد من تحقيق درجه امنه
من الاستقلال تجاه الخارج لما نتحرك في
الزمن ون وصل للتسعينات من القرن الماضي
حينما انشات منظمه التجاره العالميه يعني
هم انا اسف قبل اطع حضرتك لحظه ان اليابان
ارادت انها تحقق قدر من الاكتفاء الذاتي
يعني مبوط مش كده برض بحيث ما تكونش هي
خاضعه لضغوط العالم الخارجي اه لانه لو
انصعت ل يعني مبادئ التجاره الدوليه خلينا
نقول وال القرص الرص ارخص في دول مجاوره
مثلا اي دوله من دول الجوار تايلاند على
سبيل المثال الرز
بينتج بتقريبا ثلث او ربع تكلفته في
الابان دي المعطيات يعني انما قالك لا
موضوع امن قومي لما يعني دارت الايام
وانشات منظمه التجاره العالميه كان واحد
من اهم
البنود على جدو اعمال جوله اورجواي اللي
انتهت بانشاء منظمه التجاره العيه هو
تحرير التجاره في السلع الزراعيه فكان
الموضوع بالنسبه لليابان انه يعني لابد من
تحرير التج جاره الارز وانتم في اليابان
تدعمون الارز بنسب عاليه جدا والضحيه هو
المستهلك الياباني ده المنطق فكان الرد
الياباني والله دي قضيه امن قومي ليست
حساب تكلفه وعائد بالمعيار النقدي او
الاقتصادي المجرد واحتفظت اليابان لنفسها
بحق دعم راعه ال اي نعم حتى يومنا هذا
واعتقد
ان لم يكن يخلو من حكمه سياسيه في اداره
الشان العام لو نقلنا الى بلاد اخرى زي
مصر على فكره في المنطقه اللي اح فيها
اللي هو الوطن العربي ككل الوطن العربي في
مجموعه 22 دول بيتكلم
عليهم تقريبا كلهم مستوردين
القمح باستثناء عدد محدود من الحالات انما
في المجمل الوطن العربي بيعتمد على الخارج
في حدود 50% من احتياجاته من القمح وهذا
الموضوع ا بالحساب الاستراتيجي شديد
الخطوره لانه اذا استدعينا التجربه بتاعه
مصر مع امريكا في عهد جونسون يمكن جدا حجب
الامح عن ما من يحتاج اليه حتى وان كان
يمتلك اموال قارون لدفع ثمن الايه ثمن
القون لذلك
مثلا كان لدينا مؤتمر قريب عن الموضوع ده
والحديث عن كيف يمكن تجبيه جهد جماعي على
مستوى الدول الاعضاء في جمع الدول العربيه
لمواجهه هذه المشكله وهناك مقوله قديمه
ل اظن جبران خليل جبران له كتاب بديع جدا
عنوانه النبي اه طبعا ده ترجب للغات كثيره
جدا مب ففي هذا الكتاب المقوله مقوله
جبران انه وال
لامه اكلت خبزا لم تزرعه ولبست ثوبا لم
تصنعه اه طبعا عن كلمه بليغه
وبتلخبط سؤالي معالي الدكتور مفهوم ان هم
ممكن يمارسوا الضغط على دوله ما اي دوله
تمارس دوله على ضغط على دوله اخرى بوسائل
منها الامن الغذائي انا بتكلم على القمح
هنا الارز في دوله اخرى وهكذا بس سؤالي هم
كيف يمارسوه المفروض ان انا عندي قمح
بيكفي العالم كله يعني مثلا ارقام 22 كان
انتاج العالم من الق حوالي 800 مليون طن
استهلاك العالم كان حوالي
793 مليون طن بشكل او باخر الارقام بتختلف
من عمل اخر ولكن القمح يكفي الجميع هم
ازاي قدروا يخلوا دول محرومه تماما من
القمح هل عمليه تنظيميه هل قرارات سياسيه
من من خلال عده وسائل واحد انه يحرمك من
القمح مباشره في لحظه حاجتك اليه مثل
واقعه الستينات مبوط ولكن اه لا يقل اهميه
عن هذا ان يتدخل بوسائل مختلفه اهمها ما
يسمى المعانات او المساعدات الخارجيه
في تقليل قدرتك على انتاج ما يكفيك من
الغذاء وبالمناسبه مصر كان لها تجربه مهمه
في هذا السياق ايضا في اطار المعونه
الامريكيه او المساعدات الامريكيه
ا بحيث
انه رفع شعار انه فيزر
المصريه الافضل ان ننتج ما خف حمله وغلى
ثمنه فلو خدت الطن من الفراوله على سبيل
المثال وقرن بطن من القم حاجد انه يمكن من
خلال البيع في السوق الدوليه ان احصل من
طن الفراوله على اضعاف ما احصل عليه من طن
القمح طبعا طنم في الحسابات العاديه
للتجاره هذا مقبول ولكن في الحسابات
الاستراتيجيه لاداره شؤون مجتمع وعلاقاته
الدوليه واحتمالات الا تتطابق وجهات نظر
وان تتعارض وجهات نظر مع قوه حاكمه يبقى
في هذه الحاله هذا المنطق يقع تماما وا
الافضل ان احنا ندير المساله من منطلق
مفهوم استراتيجي ل مفهوم الامن ك فعلت
اليابان مضبوط كما فعلت اليابان كما تفعل
دول اوروبا اصلا مضبوط انما عايز بس انتهز
هذه الفرصه وانبه لنقطه
خلط يثور في اذان الكث
ان والله لابد ان نستهدف تحقيق الكتفاء
الذاتي بمعنى ان انا انتج 100% من
احتياجاتي ليه بقى هنا نستدعي الاعتبارات
الاقتصاديه مثلا الموارد المتاحه
ظروف المناخ ى اخره وفي هذه الحاله بنقول
قد تكون التكلفه الاقتصاديه اعلى مما
يحتمل الوضع باستهداف
انتاج كل الاحتياجات 100% من احتياجات طيب
ايه المطلوب انك انت تستهدف مثلا انتج 70%
من الاحتياجات وال 30% سهل تدبيرها بتكلفه
اقل من الخارج ولكن بشرط تنويع مصادر
الامداد دي مساله مهمه جدا لو خليت كل
البيت في سله واحده وجبت الجزء الاكبر من
يعني حصل معانا هذا في حاله
اوكرانيا اوكرانيا طب وروسيا كانوا من اهم
الموردين للقمح لمصر لكل دول المنطقه
مظبوط وبالتالي ده ده خطا في اداره
المساله بالنسبه له الدول من منظور الامن
الغذائي المنظور الغذائي تنتج نسبه امنه
خلينا نقول 70 60% مع تنويع مصادر الامداد
للنقطه للنسبه البقيه اذا الطريقه الاولى
لتسليح القمح في حاله دول منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وسلع اخرى اساسيه مثل الارز في شرق
اسيا على سبيل المثال هو المنع المباشر
واحد اثنين اغراء هذه الدول على المدى
الطويل باقناع انه ليس من الضروره ان
تستثمروا كثيرا في هذه السلع وان السلع
ديت شوفوا اللي يجيب كاش اكتر وفكره حضرتك
لمن لا يتابعنا اذا كان يعني من الشباب
الصغير قوي ان فعلا شاع في اسواقنا ومنهم
السوق المصري خصوصا في التسعينات انه ليه
نشغل دماغنا بالقمح والارز طب ما احنا
عندنا الكنتلوب وعندنا الفراوله وكذا
ونبيعه وب نشتري قمح مظبوط الفكره دي هي
اللي حضرتك اشرت اليها ان الدول اللي
رفضتها تماما زي اليابان وقالت حتى لو انا
هشتري الرز بسعر ارخص ده يعرض امني للخطر
اذا ارادت الدول المصدره للارز ان هي
ا تمنع عني حضرتك قلت نقطه مهمه جدا بتقول
ليس البديل هو انتاج 100% من السلعه
الرئيسيه ولكن انتاج قدر كافي من هذه
السلع مع تنويع مصادر الجزء المتبقي من
المستورد قدر امن بقدر امن ايوه هل في طرق
اخرى بتمكن الدول الكبيره من السيطره على
سوق القمح طبعا لانه نسبه المتداول بين
دول العالم في حاله القمح اعلى من
المتداول بين دول العالم في حاله سله ذيه
اخرى مثل الارز الارز اساسا يستهلك حيث
ينتج وبالتالي ما يتم
تداوله دوليا محدود محدود الوضع مختلف في
حاله القمح وهنا بيطرح قضيه كيف يتم تنظيم
تجاره القمح عالميا هناك عدد من شركات لا
يزيد عن اصابع اليد
الواحده اساسا شركات امريكيه هي الشركات
المتحكمه في تجاره
القمح طب سؤالك وكيف تتحكم هذه الشركات في
تجاره القمح معروف ان تجاره قمح تنظم عن
طريق ما يسمى بورصات السلع العالميه سواء
في شيكاغو او لندن او غيرها وان هذه الدول
الاداء المتداوله هي العقود انت بتعمل
العقد على قمح من منتج من اوكرانيا ولكن
ا يعني لا تضع
يدك نقطه مهمه جدا على القمح بس انت متحكم
في من يصل اليه القمح باعتبارك انت المالك
بحكم ورقه اسمها العقد معلش وضح لنا اني
مع دكتور يعني دوقتي ادي اوكرانيا تنتج
القمح مظبوط ادي المغرب تريد القمح عظيم
الوسيط بين الاثنين السوق العالميه في
القمح خلينا نسميها كده يعني معنى ذلك ان
حكومه المغرب لا تشتري من حكومه اوكرانيا
ولكن شركه في المغرب او حكومه المغرب ق
تشتري قمح خلينا نسميه اوكراني اه من خلال
السوق العالميه لقم عظيم السوق العالميه
بتنظم
ازاي انه العمليه كلها بتتم من خلال عقود
اوراق اه في مرحله معينه التسليم في
المرحله الاخيره جدا فعشان المغرب تشتري
قمح اوكراني لازم تدخل بورصه الس خلينا
نقول في شيكاغو او لندن
وطبقا لمجريات الامور في في هذه
البورصه تطلب
توريد
كذا م اه هذه الاطنان في الواقع هي قمح
اوكراني وليست ولكن ليس بالضروره قمح
مملوك
لاوكرانيا ملوك واحده من خمس شركات هي
التي تهيمن على تجاره
عالميا ف التعاقد
هيكون بين الحكومه الاكرانيه او الجهه
الداخله زي ماثلا هيئه سلع او بين الحكومه
المغربيه في المثال اللي احنا قلناها وبين
الشركه احد الشركات على توريد امح
اوكرانيا عظيم عظيم هنا ل نقول الذي يهيمن
على السو العالميه للح يعني بمعنى الكميه
المتداوله بين دول العالم هو مجموعه خمس
شركات فقط وهذه الشركات لها حساباتها طبعا
هي في السوق لكي تكسب مفهوم ولكن في بعض
الاحيان قد تكون هناك اعتبارات اخرى حاكمه
في قرارها التز وبالتالي كي تحصل المغرب
خلينا في مثالنا على قمح اوكراني لابد علي
ان تتعامل من خلال بورصه القمح مع الشركه
التي تهيمن على تجاره القمح اللي منشه
اوكرانيا والشركات ديت اولا عندها
اعتبارات اقتصاديه بحته في الاول ده معناه
ان هي ممكن مثلا انه يحصل عمليه تواطئ
لرفع اسعار القمح ممكن الحفاظ على الاقل
على اسعاره زي ما بتعمل الاوبك مثلا على
سبيل المثال طبعا لانه خلي بالك هو النقطه
ايه هنا انت انت عندك منتجين اعداده
الكبار لو نزلنا الى مستوى المزارعين
بالملايين صح اه وعندك مستهلكين في الهم
اعدادهم بالملايين ايضا وبالتالي المفترض
عمليا انه السوق يبقى تنفسي لانه المنتجين
والعارضين ا بالملايين والمستهلكين
والطالبين بالملايين صح ده نموذج باهر جدا
للسوق التنافسيه لكن اللي بيحصل ايه
انه الحلقه اللي في النص اه حاله سوق
الايس حاله حاله حاكمه جدا فيستحيل ملايين
المنتجين الى خمس شركات بيحصل عمليه سق
نوع من انواع الاحتكار بالضبط كده ف
الاحتكار هو اول او احد الاشكال اللي
بتخلي الدول او المؤسسات تتحكم في القمح
صحح في حاجه ثانيه لو لو هظر بقى مش من
وحي اللحظه الحاليه انما عبر الزمن بحيث
انه تتفاقم
مشكله القمح في بلد ده مرتبط اساسا
بالسياسات العامه التي تطبق في هذا البلد
و هل ممكن بايجاز معال الدكتور نفهمها
ازاي يعني بلد بتعاني من نقص القمح هنقول
مثلا ناخذ تاريخيا كان معروف انه دوله مثل
الهند اه اه كان معروف انها كل عده اعوام
تندلع فيها مجاعه كبرى جدا نتيجه لنقص
انتاج الايه القمح في الستينات كان
هناك نشاط معروف تحت يعني عنوان كبير
الثوره الخضراء جرين ريفلوشن اللي هو
استخدام معطيات العلم والتكنولوجيا لرفع
انتاجيه المساحه المزروعه قمحا ا وبفضل
تطبيق الثوره الخضراء على الزراعه في
الهند حصل طفره في انتاج الهند الى الحد
ان الهند حاليا تحولت الى احد الدول
المصدره للقح وده معناه انه لو اسقطنا
المساله على جزئا من العالم كنا نتحدث عنه
الوطن العربي هذا الموضوع يعني الثوره
الخضراء بمعنى
تطبيق
اساليب الاستنباط من خلال البحث والتجريب
لاستنباط سلالات عاليه الغله في افاق
كبيره جدا لان متوسط الانتاجيه في الجزء
هنا اقل من متوسط الانتاجيه على مستوى
العالم بنسبه معتبره فمعناها انه قدامك
افق لذات الانتاج ربما بنسبه 20 او 30% من
خلاله انما طبعا عشان تعمل ده لازم
تعبا اجهزه البحث والتطوير داخليه مثلا في
مصر ايه هي ده هي مركز البحوث الزراعيه
لوزاره الايه الزراعه بحيث انه يركز على
موضوع استنباط سلالت عاليه الغله مقاومه
لظروف
المناخيه غير المواتيه في ظل التغير
المناخي ففي مجال انما
تجربه الهند تقدم دروس كثيره جدا في
المقابل في المقابل ا وك نفهم بعض
الاحداث في المحيط القريب منا تاخد
الغليان السياسي في منطقه الساحل اه
الساحل الافريقي ايو منطقه الساحل اه طبعا
يعني الناس لا تدرك انه في الواقع لب
الموضوع تمثل فيه
ا الانسياق وراء دعوه عارمه جدا من جانب
ما يسمى المستثمرين الاجانب
ل شراء الاراضي واقتلاع الفلاحين ها التي
عاشوا على هم واجدادهم واجدادهم لزمن طويل
وابتدت
تخضع
للمنطق الراس مالي في عمليه الاثمار فترتب
على هذا انه اعداد كبيره من المزارعين
اللي كانوا
يعيشون ينتجوا ما يحتاجون اليه وعايش فيه
بساطه انت رحت حدفه في السوق مباشره ما
اصبحش منتج وعليه ان يستهلك ولا بد ان
يدبر الاحوال فده يعني اربك المعادله
السياسيه في الداخل و اقول ان هذا هو
السبب الوحيد انما واحد من اهم الاسباب
التي لابد من ان نلتفت اليها لما تزور
كثير من المدن العربيه بالمناسبه وتاخذ
دمشق على سبيل المثال ستذهل من كميه
التوسعات في محيط مدينه دمشق من القادمين
من الارياف الارياف ونفس الشيء طبعا في
حاله في حاله مصر احد اهم الاسباب هو
اهمال الزراعه رغم اني اعلم يقينا انه
الاهتمام بالزراعه في حاله سوريا كان اكبر
كثيرا من الاهتمام بالزراعه في حاله مصر
ولكن الهجره من الريف الى المدن احد
اسبابها هو انه الزراعه لم تعد تتيح القدر
الكافي من الامان الاقتصادي دعنا نقول
لهذه الجموع
فيعني خرجت الى المدينه انا استاذنك
انه اتعملت دراسات متعدده ان احد اسباب
الدوافع الرئيسيه للاضطرابات في سوريا
بدايه من مارس 2011 سبب رئيسي وليس السبب
الوحيد طبعا هو كان وجود اهمال
للزراعه ونتيجه هذا الاهمال ادى الى هجرات
من المزارعين قبل 2011 الى المدن بالسنوات
اللي سبقتها وبالتالي هاجروا اهريه جم
لمدن اصبحوا فقراء وبالتالي ده كان احد
اسباب الغليان يعني اه اذا كان حرك تتفق
يعني معه استاذنك في توضيح لما معالي
الدكتور بيقول على مشكله دول الساحل واحنا
تكلمنا عنها في حلقات كثيره يعني ولكن
بيشير الى بعض المستثمرين اللي بيجوا من
دول اخرى دول الخليج دول اوروبا حتى من
مصر عندنا في مستثمرين راحوا الى هذه
الدول وبياخد كميات كبيره من الاراضي
بيستغل لاغراض الربح بالدرجه الاولى عشان
ينتج ما يريد لبيعه في السوق ده على حساب
مزارع كان موجود بينتج حاجته الاساسيه
وحاجه بلده فادى الى اختفاء سلعه اساسيه
في هذه الدول فادى ذلك الى اضطرابات هذا
ما تقصده الورده صحيح خلق يعني كتله حرجه
من الضغوط
الاجتماعيه في صوره
ال المهاجرين من الريف الى المدينه مع عجز
المدينه عن استعاب هذه العد الكبيره سواء
من ناحيه الثقافه وسائل العيش وايضا
وايضا ذات اليد بمعنى انه فقد مصدر دخله
لانه لم يعد
منتجا ياخد اشغال هامشيه في ا في المدينه
فده نتج عنه الظاهره اللي بنسميها
المعروفه حاليا ظاهره ترييف المدن ترييف
المدن ترييف المدن لان المدينه اصبحت خليط
لم تعد كما كانت لا واظن كمان معال
الدكتور في وفقا للساق الحاج بتقوله انا
كمستثمر لما رحت السودان او رحت نيجيريا
او رحت اي بلد انا ممكن استغل ال 0000
فدان دول لاعتبارات ان انا عاوز اسرع مثلا
زيوت نباتيه جيده ومفيده ولكن انا عاوز
استهدف بها السوق البريطاني السوق
الاوروبي مش احتياجات هذا البلد من الامح
والذره والرز الاحتياجات صحيح ولكن دعني
يستدعي نقطه مهمه في هذا السياق في الحاله
المصريه تحديدا نحن نعلم ان هناك
استثمارات بعض مستثمرين من
الخليج في مناطق استصلاح الاراضي الجديده
في شرق العينات وتوشكا كويس ما هي
الزراعات التي تتم
هناك البرسيم البرسيم الحجازي البرسيم
الحجازي ايوه طيب ايه اهميه البرسيم
الحجازي اقتصاديا اه من عده وجود نمره
واحد انه محصول شاره جدا
للمياه وبالتالي فان زراعه البرسيم
وتصديره الى دول الخليج يستخدم علف
للماشيه لكن ينتج لحوم تتداول عن طريق
السلاسل التجاريه الكبرى
للمطاعم وطبعا مش هنذكر البنامج الماركات
الكل عارف الماركات دي فاللي عايز يعرف
هذه السلاسل ما هي لحوم قادمه من مصر
وغيرها طبعا من الدول وا الاداء هي توظيف
المساحات الزراعيه والمياه كميات المياه
لانتاج القارن بين انك تزرع بقرار مساحات
في الصحاري المصريه الجديده شار العوينات
وتوشكا بالبرسيم الحجازي او بالقمح من حيث
الشكل تقريبا المس من حيث التاثير
الاقتصادي مساله كبيره جدا جدا المثال مهم
جدا وينطبق على دول كتيره انه حضرتك قلت
المثل للمره الثانيه مستثمرين بياخدوا
عشرات الالاف من الافدنه صحيح بيزرع برسيم
حجازي بيستهلك كميات كبيره من الميه
المحدوده و بياخدها بطلعها لدول الخليج في
المطاعم اللي هي سلاسل المطاعم المشهوره
ده يحقق ربح للدوله على المدى القصير ممكن
ولكن على المدى الطويل هو بيحرم من الفرصه
الاستثمار البديله وهي القمح اللي يعمل لك
مبوط وايضا يحرمها من اهم الموارد
الزراعيه وهو المياه وهو المياه ولذلك
بتسمى هذه العمليه سيد تصدير برسيم حجازي
مثلا وده ينطبق على كل السلع كثيفه
استخدام المياء بيسمى التصدير الافتراضي
للمياه فيرتوال وتر اكسبورت شن انه بتصدر
الزرع جزء من مكوناته المياه فانت بتصدر
مياه في اه المكون الاساسي للمياه عندي
الاخير معال الدكتور انا اذكر حضرتك قلت
لي واذكر ان انا
قريت لحضرتك في احد كتبك انه لما توليت
وزاره التموين في 2011 2012 ان جاءك ضيف
غير مدعو اكثر من مره بيلح في السؤال عن
شيء معين من هذا الضيف وما هو وما هو
الموضوع اللي كان بيلح عليه
ا يعني انا حد فاكر اسمه لغد دلوقت لايوم
هو طبعا موقعه كان
المستشار الزراعي للسفاره الامريكيه في
القاهره اه وده بال كان اول ضيف اجنبي
يجيلك يجيلي يهنيني بالمنصب الجديد كوزير
اه جاي اخضر كده من الجامعه لكرسي الوزاره
وهو جاي بصحبه السفيره الامريكيه انما
طبعا السفيره جت ومشيت وبقي هو وكان
تقريبا عنده معدل زياره لمكتبي كل شهر كل
شهر على الجدول يطلب لقاء لم يكن هو فقط
انما كان هناك شخص اخر مهم بالنسبه لقضيه
القمح التي تتحدث عنها هذا الشخص هو رئيس
رابطه مصدي الحبوب في فرنسا اوكي عندي
الفرنسي ده والامريكيون داما زروك مش مع
بعض انما لهم معدل كده كل شهر
مره الموضوع الرئيسي للحديث كان ان والله
مصر في ذلك الحين كان عندها تجربه وعده
وهي التنويع
في مجال انتاج الخبز او العيش كما نسميه
بخلط دقيق الذره بدقيق القمح في انتاج
الرغيف احنا عندنا انتاج جيد من الذره
عندنا انتاج جيد
وبمعية من القمح بالمعيار الاقتصادي
وبالتالي
حينما يتم انتاج رغيف بخلط الذره مع القمح
في الانتاج تصبح التكلفه اقل ويقل اعتمادك
على الخارج لان تقدر تنتج اكثر من هذه
السياسه في الواقع لابد للامانه
والانصاف ان اردها الى صاحبها لم تكن من
اعدياتي عنما كان الدكتور احمد جويلي الذي
كان وزير لتين قبل مني بوزين يعني هو مشي
وج اثنين وزرا بعدين وبعدين جيت انا فهو
اللي بدا فكره انتاج وطبعا استاذ اخصا
زراعي ودارس الموضوع انتاج ده استدعى بعض
التعديل في البنيه التحتيه لانتاج الخبز
لانه في اشتراطات معينه
لدرع
لكي يصبح امنا استخدامه في انتاج غذائ
الانسان هي قضيه التحميص لانه لو لو لما
يتم تحميصه بعد تنقيته من كل السوائل
داخله
سيصبح بيئه حيويه لانتشار سموم واضرار
كبيره ج ده تم الكلام ده و في كل مطحن عول
يعني عولج طبعا عولج وابتدت تجارب 5% ثم
10% وصل لمستوى 10% بمعنى 10% من الدقيق
مصدره الذره و 90% مصدر العم ده اقلل
استيراد 10% من الق بالضبط كده
لا تتخيل لا تتخيل ا انا استشعرت هذا كم
الازعاج الذي شعرت به امريكا وشعرت به
فرنسا من هذا
الموضوع ليه بقى لان خلي بالك لما تكون
مصر
والقمح هذه قصه اخرى تختلف عن كل القصص
لان مصر هي اكبر مستورد للمح على مستوى
العالم فكل طم طن قمح انخفاض في استيراد
مصر ممكن يهز الايه البورصات هكذا الوضع
لا بد يدرك هذا ورقه كبيره جدا وبالمناسبه
يعني تفريع انا استخدمت هذه الورقه للضغط
على الروس للسماح بدخول البطاطس المصريه
لما لوحت بورقه القمح ف انصع ودخلوه نعود
لموضوع الراجل ده كان كل شويه طبعا المدخل
ايه المدخل انه الذره ممكن يسبب امراض زي
البلاجرا وخلافه وكلام من ده ونفس القصه
مع الفرنسي فانا لقيت حيله لطيفه جدا
دكتور اللي ق حلته هو بقول لك عليه جاب
رغيفين رغيف من العادي ورغيف من الهجين ها
المخلوط ودعى الراجل الامريكاني ده وجاب
ملاحه وقال له تعال بقى في بلدنا بنقول
ناكل عيش وملح تعال ناكل عيش عزمه على
الرغيف والملح وفلفل فبيس الراجل ايه رايك
في القل ده ممتاز جدا قال له ده الرغيف
المخلوط ده الرغيف المخلوط ومش هيحصل لك
حاجه انا طبعا لقيت حيله ثانيه ا
جبت عارف سيد لما تبص للقمح المنتج محليا
والقمح المستورد فرق السماء والارض ب
القمح المصري زي العقيق عارف يعني الحبه
ممتلئه واللون بتاعها يعني فياض كده ها
الثاني لا شكله بين الرمادي والبني وال
فجبت برطمانين مليت واحد قمح محلي وواحد
قمح متصور وحطيتهم على مكتبي وكتبت عليهم
قمح حلي كل ما يجي الناس دول رحت موريه
البرطمنات واقول له بس خلي بالك احنا لا
نخلط لا نخلط القمح المستورد من عندكم
بالذره انليت بالقمح المنتج محليا ليه لان
في حاجه اسمها نسبه الجيلاتين في في الحبه
فنسبه الجيلاتين في
الحبه المصريه اللي هي بتديلك
التماسك للمنتج اعلى بكتير من النسبه فيتا
فقول له وبالتالي مافيش مشكله على الاطلاق
لان نوعيه القمح المصري افضل من نوعيه
القمح ومع ذلك هذا الموضوع يشكل هجس كبير
لهذه الدول وان دل هذا على شيء اللي يدل
على البعد الاستراتيجي العالمي لمساله
القمح الذي يستدعي ان تكون الحسابات ليست
الحسابات الاقتصاديه المجرده وان حسابات
استراتيجيه تتناسب مع خطوره هذه السلا اخر
سؤال لو في اجابه يا دكتور في دقيقه مثلا
عشان انا عارف ان وقت حضرتك قليل جدا طيب
حضرتك المساله طرحت ايام الدكتور جويلي
يعني من حوالي مثلا 15 سنه اكتر من 15 سنه
ثم حضرتك استانفت مر دلوقتي حوالي 20 سنه
على طرح الفكره لماذا لم تنفذ حتى الان لا
ده تم التراجع انا يعني احنا بعد ا طبعا
للاسف الشديد لانه احنا كنا وصلنا لمستوى
10 اه وكانت هناك تجارب
في لا عندنا في مصر في حاجه اسمها معهد
بحوث الخبز اللي هي اجر في الدراسات
للوصول الى النسبه المثلى والشروط بتاعه
الخلط بين الاثنين فكان استؤنف النشاط
بانه ترفع النسبه الى 15 توطئه لرفعها الى
20 في نهايه المتب وده كان 20% ذره و 80%
ليه تم التراجع ب تم التراجع بضغوط حلف
غير مقدس انا بسميه اه وكتبت عن هذا في
كتاب من الميدان الى الديوان هذا الحلف
يتمثل من جزئيه هناك
ظهير من بني قلتنا اللي هم تجار الارز
مستوردين الارز مستوردين القمح المستوردين
اه مستوردين القمح
والشركات المصدره للقمح عالميا اللي هم
الخمسه الكبار والخمسه الكبار ولكن الخمسه
الكبار مش في الصوره هم بينوب عنهم مر
المستشار الزراعي لسفاره امريكا مره رئيس
رابطه مصدر الحبوب ف هذا الحلف غير المق
ضغوط من الداخل وضغوط من الخارج تتوافق
معا على تحقيق مصالحها الخاصه على حساب
المصلحه الوطنيه العليا وبالتالي يؤسفني
ان اقول ان هذه
التجربه المنعشه والعده تم التراجع عنها
تماما والان رغيف الخبز المدعم ينتج بنسبه
100% من
القمح
55% منها امريكي فرنسي وكراني الى اخره 45
او 50 من
الداخل جزيل الشكر معالي الدكتور استاذنك
نستانف الحديث عن
ا هذا الموضوع وموضوعات اخرى يعني مهمه في
حلقات اخرى وطبعا حضرتك يعني الاجابه
صادمه لكن لا بس ده الواقع ودي قضيه يعني
سياسه عامه وبالتالي هي ملك كل ناس لا
ينبغي ان تكون فقط قاصره على متخذي القرار
متخذي القرار ينبغي ان يعل انهم في نهايه
الامر يسائلون من القاعده العريضه من
المنتج القمح من ناحيه لا معنى على
الاطلاق لدعم الفلاح الامريكي او الفلاح
الفرنسي على حساب الفلاح المصري جزيل
الشكر معال الدكتور عفوا شكرا جزيلا
لحضراتكم ونلقاكم في حلقات اخرى من سلسله
افكار الاستاذ مع الدكتور جود عبد الخالق
الى اللقاء